what do i want
what i want is to wake up and see my mom
again
for things to go back to the way they
were
when my life made sense but that's not
gonna happen and
it's all my fault
my mom the accident the fact that she's
dead she got scraped off some highway
because of me because of my stupid
audition because she was rushing because
i made a promise to come
and when they called my name i was mad
at her
because i needed her to be there for me
and she wasn't
she was dying while i was dancing and i
was mad at her and i'm sorry
i'm sorry
she just wanted to be there for me and
that's what makes it so bad
she always wanted what was right for me
i wanted to be the prima ballerina i had
to be and i didn't care if it took all
of
our money and all of her spare time
it was my stupid audition
in my stupid dream and it killed her
all she ever wanted was for it to come
true